nos preguntan qué imagen divide un
círculo en cuartos cuartos es lo mismo
que dividirlo en cuatro partes iguales
vemos las opciones aquí tengo este
círculo que está dividido en cuatro
partes 1 2 3 4 y cada parte es igual así
que esta sería la opción correcta pero
vamos a revisar las otras opciones aquí
el círculo está dividido también en 1 2
3 4 partes pero no son iguales entre sí
esta parte de acá no es igual a esta
parte entonces esta no es una opción
correcta esta otra opción no se está
dividiendo el círculo a la mitad en dos
mitades no en cuatro partes esa tampoco
es correcta y esta opción nos está
dividiendo en círculo en una dos tres
partes iguales pero no en cuatro así que
efectivamente esta primera opción es la
correcta
comprobamos respuesta
es correcto hagamos otro ejercicio
ahora resolvamos este ejercicio qué
imagen divide un cuadrado en cuartos
nuevamente es dividirla en cuatro en
cuatro partes iguales
esto significa cuartos veamos la primera
opción aquí tenemos un cuadrado completo
no está dividido así que esta no es aquí
tengo un cuadrado que está dividido a la
mitad en dos partes iguales aquí en
diagonal pero no está dividido en cuatro
partes así que no me sirve esta otra
también tengo un cuadrado dividido igual
por la mitad pero ahora verticalmente
pero no está dividido en cuatro partes
así que no es mi respuesta esta última
opción
veo que el cuadrado está dividido en
1234 partes y cada una de esas partes
son iguales esta es la opción correcta y
vamos a comprobar la respuesta
es correcto hagamos otro ejercicio de
imagen divide un rectángulo en mitades
mitades significa a la mitad o en dos
partes iguales veamos la primera opción
me está dividiendo el rectángulo en 123
partes iguales pero yo solo quiero que
se divide en dos no en tres esta no me
sirve esta medida del rectángulo en 123
partes pero para nada son partes iguales
y además son 3
esta opción me divide el rectángulo a la
mitad y estas dos partes son iguales son
triángulos idénticos si este triángulo
lo volteáramos y lo parábamos quedaría
de esta forma estos dos triángulos son
iguales y me están dividiendo el
rectángulo en dos partes iguales
esta es la correcta la última opción me
está dividiendo el rectángulo en 123
partes iguales pero yo necesito que esté
en dos en mitades comprobamos la
respuesta es correcta veamos el
siguiente problema
imagen divide el círculo en cuartos en
cuatro partes vemos la primera opción
que me lo está dividiendo en 123 partes
iguales pero quedamos que cuartos son
cuatro partes iguales este no me sirve
este me lo divide en uno dos tres cuatro
partes pero no son partes iguales este
no me sirve esta opción me la divide en
1 2 3 4 partes y cada una de estas
partes son iguales entre sí esta es la
opción correcta y la última opción vemos
que nos divide el círculo en partes
iguales pero sólo en dos en mitades 1 y
2 esta no me sirve compruebo respuesta
es correcta tenemos un problema más que
imagen divide un cuadrado a la mitad a
la mitad quiere decir que lo estoy
partiendo en dos partes iguales veamos
aquí esta opción
tengo una dos tres partes pero me están
pidiendo que esté dividido a la mitad en
dos partes iguales y no en tres esta no
es aquí tengo dos partes de este
cuadrado pero no son iguales no está
dividido a la mitad de hecho este es un
tercio esta no me sirve aquí tengo el
cuadrado dividido en unos 23 partes pero
para nada son iguales esta parte está
muy chiquita esta no me sirve porque
estoy buscando un cuadrado a la mitad la
última opción pues es la correcta tengo
aquí esta línea que me divide el
cuadrado exactamente por la mitad
dejándome dos partes iguales esta es la
opción correcta por favor respuesta y es
correcta veamos un ejercicio más que
imagen dividió un rectángulo en cuartos
recordamos que cuartos
es dividirlo en cuatro partes iguales
tengo aquí esta opción que tengo 1 2 3 4
partes y cada una de ellas es igual esta
opción me está dividiendo el rectángulo
en cuartos la siguiente opción me lo
está dividiendo a la mitad en dos partes
pero no es lo que me piden esta opción
me está dividiendo este rectángulo en
dos partes iguales pero tampoco es lo
que me piden y la última opción lo está
dividiendo en 123 partes iguales pero
estamos buscando cuartos que es la
primera opción comprobamos respuestas
es correcta